now jenn sake signed off as white house
press secretary today ending her tenure
as biden's chief spokeswoman and
propagandist where she spewed endless
lies flip-flops false narratives and
played a never-ending blame game here's
a quick trip down memory lane watch this
you may have noticed this week that your
gas prices have gone up i want to talk
to you a little bit about why a lot of
it has to do with vladimir putin
it's broadly known and widely known
peter that there was a broad range of
russian disinformation back in 2020. why
is the administration flying thousands
of migrants from the border to florida
and new york in the middle of the night
well i'm not sure that it's in the
middle of the night as individuals come
across the border
and
they are both assessed for whether they
have
any symptoms if they have symptoms they
are the intention is for them to be
quarantined that is our process they're
not intending to stay here for a lengthy
period of time you still believe that
but ill back better will not add a dime
to the national debt
correct it won't why would why should
americans believe that because it won't
people it was it was crystal clear that
things were not improving on supply
chain people couldn't get dishwashers
and
and furniture and treadmills delivered
on time not to mention all sorts of
other things so why is the tragedy of
the short the treadmill that's delayed
and last thing i want to do before we
get to your questions
i often note i'm going to circle back i
hate to disappoint conservative twitter
but i'm going to circle back on a number
of things as we often do directly
yeah boy that's not what we were working
for in the 80s and 90s all these
generations with feminism now i'm sure
saki will be right at home over at msdnc
where she can continue to act as an arm
of the democratic party and continue to
spend endless spin endlessly for what is
an imploding biden presidency and
failing agenda on monday new white house
press secretary karine jean-pierre will
take over the podium where we can expect
to hear more of the same excuses for the
same reckless far-left policies here now
for reaction fox news contributors joe
koncha and david webb
you know joe as i've intimated here you
know a lot of women and men have worked
for a couple of generations now to get
women in positions of power uh and we
are now watching this with the first
female vice president a woman who's the
head of the department of energy uh
women who are generally now the press
secretaries and they have thrown their
lot in with the lying batch and they've
just sold it all out and that you know
it's it's heartbreaking for this country
but we have a chance to change it and
fix it for jen sake maybe a year and a
half here for joe biden what do you
think she's going to try to do when
she's actually on television more of the
same or will she change it up
oh i think it'll be more of the same the
problem is tammy is that without peter
ducey there as a foil then jen saki
becomes
patently
very not interesting right uh she was
with cnn for years that's right and i
don't remember any segment where she
stood out as some sort of great
communicator or somebody who could make
a really compelling argument passionate
argument so i i don't see her really
being this big success that people are
portraying her to be when she goes to
her next job and i can't remember by the
way any press secretary who had this
sort of
self-congratulatory farewell tour like
this one she's had over the last month
and some have said including one former
sunday anchor on this network that jen
saki was one of the best
and greatest press secretaries like ever
wow if that's the case then why has her
boss and joe biden and his agenda failed
so craptastically both in practice and
on the messaging front let's look at the
scoreboard right miss sake is reportedly
the brainchild behind putin price hike
right that hashtag in regards to
inflation has been rising for 16 months
how is that message resonating because a
recent nbc news poll her future network
tammy only six percent of american
voters blame vladimir putin for the
current inflation crisis so if she's
just great communicator then what's
going on here well yeah and david maybe
you can shed some light here because my
my sense is with so many flip-flops you
know the press secretary is supposed to
be someone who comes out of the meetings
knows the narrative the conversations
the work that's being done in the white
house and in the administration comes
forward with the binder of information
that we saw kaylee mcinerney do all the
time
answering the details of questions about
the missions and what was being
accomplished
she says something one day to clarify
what joe biden says he says something
that then contradicts her it's like
david it's like they're winging it and
like there's no meetings that she's
going to is she been just a front person
or is she really someone who's learned
something in this process
first of all never follow the circus and
never follow joe koncha on media
analysis but i'll give it my best
did jen snarky actually read the job
description let's go and look at sarah
huckabee sanders
let's look at dana perino two people we
know well here their job was to bring
the administration's message forward
right jen snarky put her message forward
like her farewell tour she was still
playing the front woman in this case
rather than the messenger for the
administration she made it up she
circled back this move to msnbc will be
no different they're looking for a
replacement at some point maybe for
rachel maddow who know will show up for
work maybe once or twice like a democrat
congressman maybe they'll do something
she's going from a federal salary to a
high paying salary she's failed upwards
while the american people pay the price
and she just steps circling back and
circling back or blaming it on someone
else so she didn't do her job according
to the description of the job which is
messenger for the white house and the
message that's not saying their message
was coherent at times it was incoherent
and all they could think about was new
clever catchphrases that are pull tested
for months to see how far they could use
something which then turns on them this
is this is monumental failure tammy and
sad sadly the world is watching this
wait until we get kpj yeah that that's
the i don't nothing will change look
these are are women who i i think joe
they they understand that their their
job is to protect the image that there
is a functioning white house and that's
what it seems like she's been doing uh
what uh whoever is behind that podium
who they can get to do it that's going
to be their job and so they're activists
effectively simone sanders who left the
uh the kamala harris office also has had
a new show and that has not done well
joe do you think it's going to translate
do you think democrats will watch this
because
she worked for biden or do you think
that it's because she's famous and do
you think she'll
fail at this what do you think her
future will end up being
tammy i'm not sure there's much of a
base for the joe bryden
brand overall right
when you're at 33 percent approval and
when you're at nixing kind of numbers
like nixon last days nixon numbers when
it comes to your your head right your
handling of the economy or inflation or
the border uh
i don't see that being something that
transfers because there's not much of a
base there to begin with and and again
jenn saki was joe biden's spokesperson
uh is she really going to the press
secretary hall of fame at this point
considering how low his numbers are and
how the message has so
badly resonated back i have to say
actually it's the lack it's the lack
gentleman of empathy
that this is what they seem to all share
right i mean joe it's like her comment
about the treadmill the thing about call
a doctor because of the
shortage you're supposed to be you've
been hired by the american people to not
only not ruin our lives but to make it
better and her reaction jen saki's
reaction
is to mock and to ridicule people who
are suffering in this country joe am i
going too far in describing her attitude
no i mean this is the same press
secretary tammy that insisted that
skyrocketing crime police officers being
targeted like we've never seen before in
this country is only a fox news talking
point right you know right why not go to
ask any of those police chiefs in new
york or philadelphia atlanta chicago
minneapolis los angeles san francisco
portland if the record murder rate's
there is a talking point of this network
they will tell you that is not the case
so yes she is patently condescending
that will not play well on television
good luck with your new job you've had
it basically for a year to have for a
month and a half anyway and you should
have resigned six eight weeks ago but
she did not the left uh the left tends
to try to take care of their own uh and
uh we'll see what that brings them in
the meantime the rest of us are saving
the country and saving the future for
the families of this nation david joe
thank you very much sir i think
appreciate you being here hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else